hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
going to finish up what we started
yesterday which was that faculty
component and we pulled in some new data
so I did just a little bit with it after
yesterday's stream so it shouldn't be
too hard to catch everyone up we've got
a lot to do so I'm gonna try to work
fast and get as much done as I can and
before we go to the code I'm gonna fill
you in on the steps needed before we
launch because we're getting close close
enough that that list of steps is not
that long so let's do that let me get it
pulled over on on the screen here
alright so I'm gonna copy and paste this
into my editor I think if it'll let me
know I think it's gonna let me know
alright I just have to bring it over
and copy
all right there we go I was trying to
copy a checklist from Google keep and
evidently you it doesn't let you so but
you can copy it to a Google Doc so
here's my to-do list that I've just
named to do today because every day is
today so then I don't have to change the
name for different days of the week so
hopefully you can you can see this list
here's some stuff that I've had on here
previously and yes I do have to remind
myself to eat that is on my list several
times so here's what's what's left so
let's finish the faculty page component
we're going to do that in today's stream
or at least get pretty close and I'll
finish up later so that should be done
then we're going to update that faculty
list component so we just need to plug
in that data that we've got so that
should be pretty easy because we can
just copy and paste a lot of what we've
done in the faculty component into the
faculty this component so those two
there's a good chance these two it could
be done today all right we need to pull
in that data for those sample schedules
so if you remember a few streams ago we
made that sample schedule component and
we weren't using real data right we
brought in some data and we need to get
that data from WordPress since we we did
a couple of streams on trying to get
that data into our graph QL from from WP
graph QL to make it work with that
plugin couldn't get that to work so to
me I see that as a big time sink that I
don't have time for right now so I'm
gonna put that on hold and I'm just
gonna go with what I know works we're
gonna get that data from the REST API
unfortunately it's gonna mean that we
have to make to API calls per page on
the pages that have these schedules one
for the graph QL one for the REST API
but I think that it is going to be
faster to implement than trying to
modify some
WordPress plugins at least for me at
this point it is I need to double-check
the menu links on the top and side nav
I've noticed sometimes when I'm clipping
clicking around is taking me to the
wrong page so I'm not sure why that's
happening I need to go in and
double-check just to see what's going on
and then I'd like to push all the
changes to dev so this needs to happen
by the end of the day today so I don't
know if I'll get through all these but
definitely by the end of the day today I
want to push changes to that dev trance
ISKCON university so that that's
up-to-date I can't remember the last
time I I put the changes there and I
need to get this link out to some people
at the University so we can't go live
until I get approval from some people so
that's that's kind of gonna be a hold up
for us so where my boss is trying to
schedule that meeting right now he's
thinking we might not be able to get the
meeting until the first week of August
so that makes our launch date maybe the
second week of August somewhere around
there and I mean if we can get the
meeting in sooner that'd be awesome but
that's no matter whether the site's done
or not before then we can't launch until
so approval so other thing we want to do
is create a floating side menu so I have
all the data I need now for those menus
and we'll create that if you're not sure
what that is don't worry about it we'll
stream about that and then we'll put the
data in for that we need to finish that
search component and I've got new data
in for the search URLs as I mentioned
yesterday and so my student workers are
working on completing that data once
that's completed we can pull the data in
we should be able to finish that search
page and then we need to make sure that
our search inputs on the side nav and on
the top nav for desktop that bar you
know they actually work and I need to
build a custom admissions landing page
so I've sketched out just in my notebook
some designs for this so I just need to
follow those sketches to build out a
landing page because the
basically the admissions department
needs to approve this website before it
goes live because it's going to this
website will most directly impact the
work that they're doing since it's
geared towards incoming students so
that's who I have to get a meeting with
the vice president of admissions and the
Director of Admissions need to sign off
on that so I want to make that
particular page look as good as possible
and then finally the advance if I have
time I want to add that advanced custom
field data to WP graph QL so I don't
have to use the REST API and make
multiple API calls so that's it I'm sure
I'll find other stuff in the site then
he's done but basically the this is the
step to launch to launching everything
so I get all these done get approval and
the site can launch alright so just
wanted to give you all an overview I
know I do get asked somewhat frequently
when the site's going to launch by
people at the University and by by you
all you know in the stream or in social
media so I just wanted to give you a
heads up on that okay let me start my
Pomodoro timer and we can get started on
on this which yesterday I don't know
that we had this data in here so here's
what I've done since yesterday so hey
everyone I see some of you in the in the
chat don't want to leave you hanging hey
what's going on today is there is there
a soccer or football on today again I
get no viewers when this football
Stevens has come to Austin and gets
let's get some ramen that would be
awesome
I'm a big fan of ramen and I haven't had
it in so long
partly because I was on a diet for a
while but my my weight is pretty good
right now so I definitely need some
ramen ok so here's what I did I added in
these fields
for just just a bunch of spans for all
those different things you can see here
the job title email phone number and
then that that curriculum vitae that CV
field but I added in the check so we had
talked yesterday about making sure we
need to check to see if that date is
actually there so that's what I've added
in here is a just a check to see like
does that exist
if it does exist and then get it so what
I'm gonna do to test this out is I'm
gonna go in and take away some data so
let's just let's take out this phone
number and update so we will no longer
have a phone number and hopefully the
page won't break what's why doesn't know
let me update
I may have to log in again alright cool
what worked that time alright so let's
go back here refresh all right cool so
look the the phone number didn't show up
at all but you can see we didn't get an
error because we've checked here and
we're only conditionally trying to
render the value of that field alright
so if there is if this exists then we
get the value and we put that in our
span tag if it doesn't exist nothing
happens right so that's what we need
that a check for each thing in here so
we probably will need to do that as well
for all this up here to will we yeah we
will but for now let's just get this
formatting sorted so let me put that
phone number back in
Update
okay cool so we should have the number
again great alright so here's what I'm
thinking in terms of getting is you know
looking better
I did some I already did some updates on
fonts making these these headers a
little bit nicer these headers are way
too small so I still need these are
eight sixes so we need to up that for
sure this this text here the main text
is at 18 pixels I believe that these h3s
are also around 18 pixels as well at
least I I think yeah so I mean maybe if
I just if I bump this up a little bit it
should work I want to keep that visual
hierarchy but I don't want things to get
like so huge that it's kind of
ridiculous so we'll probably play around
with the CSS on these just a bit see
what looks right but you can see these
are outside of our container so we just
need to move our container class up a
level so it encompasses all of this and
that's going to bring this all into
alignment I definitely don't want the
default link styling so we're gonna
apply some of the the link styling that
we've already we already have kind of
across the board on the site we're just
going to make sure that applies to this
as well and then we're going to display
all this information you know kind of
stacked on top of each other so that's
the plan right now let's deal with the
easiest things first so here our content
div let's see if it's a steady content
so we have we've said this div with the
data attest ID of content we're given a
max width of 90% margin:0 auto so let's
do this differently I wonder what we
didn't put this in some of these other
styles oh because we have no Styles at
all all right then well you know what we
can do we didn't put any styles into
here before because we were pulling all
the mark-up end but now we we can change
that so we can pull out some of these so
let's just copy over us from a different
component some of our styles here okay
faculty
what do you all think is it better to
put our styles at the top of the
component or at the bottom of the
component I always put them at the top
but the other project that I was working
on by the way I finished my work my
piece of the work for the balance app so
there's still more to be done so I'm not
sure when it's gonna launch but I'm
finished with that now so hopefully I'll
free up a little bit of time for me but
anyway when I was working on that they
had the styles underneath and I kind of
liked that because you don't when you
start to get a lot of styles it it's a
lot of scrolling before you actually get
to the component so I don't know let's
try to put them down below for now and
just kind of see see how that how that
go see how we like it all right so let's
see what cost can only be used in a
Dutch that's ridiculous okay
I so don't need root here I need
let's just call this content I'm sorry
container make this container I want to
see with you what y'all think about the
styles here so I'm going to the chat
just for a second
Steven says I prefer the bottom I feel
like it's more convenient if you need to
come in and make changes
how many styles in every matters nikki
says four styles as long as you're
consistent over the entire app all the
top are all at the bottom okay yeah I do
I like that I know we've done everything
at the top so far it wouldn't really be
that big of a deal to switch things to
the bottom just a little copy and
pasting so I don't know I'm gonna try it
out on the bottom I kind of like it and
then if I really do like it we want to
stick with it I'll make an issue about
changing the styles and then maybe
somebody will come in and do it and if
not at some point when I get some some
time I'll go do it or maybe each time I
open up a new component make an edit
I'll flip the styles of that component
to the bottom you know I mean there's
there's just there's a couple of ways we
can make that happen but for today we'll
try it try it here and I'm I am a little
bit concerned as to why it's telling me
that I can't use Const that's really
weird
am i putting this in the wrong oh you
know what it might it shouldn't affect
cost but it might be mad that I put this
inside of here
okay that should be better container and
we can put in max with 100%
nope that's the wrong thing max with 90%
and margin yeah Auto all right cool
now we can go to this div and add style
equals Styles the container set out
there we go
and I believe we can get rid of this
data test ID I don't think we need that
anymore
and we can also get rid of it in here
oops you know what we got to do this
media query as well I can never remember
the syntax for a media query in when
we're doing styles like this but I know
we've used it elsewhere so let's go with
I think what would be the fastest way to
do this maybe just look it up in
material UI because I can't remember
what component I did this in media
queries
with with nucleus there we are okay so
we can use these theme breakpoints so
just copy and paste that here yeah and
we had a 600 pixel let me see what these
points equate to alright small is 600
pixels or larger so yep - that
corresponds awesome exactly what we need
down all right so we don't went down we
went up so we want small which is 600
pixels and up we're gonna give it a max
width of 70 70% anything below that the
max was going to be 90
all right and then that way we don't
have these huge white gaps on small
screens that are just way too big save
that see how it's working oops let's
take this out first
okay syntax error
that's weird all right why is it giving
me that I've done something wrong well
since we have this on the screen already
let's look up how it was done your con
styles well they have styles equal steam
with styles do I need that with Styles I
not have that on this component
I do not okay
yeah I don't we can just grab with wait
a second go through it with data there
we go with styles I didn't see it in
here before
oh it's all the way at the top okay
when I first copy this over I looked
here to see if there's something else I
need and just did not see that one okay
throw that in there and then we need to
change up how we're gonna do this so I'm
gonna copy everything over and then just
adapt what's down here so rude okay so
she should be able to just do this
add in another yep there we go alright
let's see if it works now still doesn't
work come on
Hey in is here how's it going inner
thanks for joining us
shoot what am I doing wrong
oh you know what let's see where's a
page from actually using this not
another sample schedule styles
so oh I know I know I put two brackets
instead of just one so if I was going to
actually put like an inline style here I
do need two brackets because the second
set of brackets would mean it's a it's
an object but I'm not trying to put an
object in here I'm trying to put in a
variable a constant so that was my
problem I mean the other stuff of
importing I would have to have done that
anyway so I'm glad I put that in theme
is not defined what
oh did I use I think I need the theme
for the break points to work
and where's let's see how we do that
here styles theme and I'm gonna put
everything in an arrow function okay all
right
all right one more time all right cool
what works but it no it's not all right
let's see
where is
assistive alright let's see what we did
okay so on this div we put this style
these containers styles and those were
the same styles that we had over here we
just brought him over okay
that's kind of weird so I'm assuming
it's this div but it looks like there's
no the styles that we want to be applied
there or not being applied and let me go
back to the console
we're not getting any warning thats
related to that to let this week has
been rough on the streams things that
should just happen that are very simple
that we've done a million times are just
not working okay alright let me go back
to here and see who's done Oh
okay well there's one thing I messed up
I put this outside when it should have
been inside
see that makes any difference at all
so nothing okay see
and see how they apply these
ah this is why
because stars
I don't know so this doing it like this
works here but I think we need to do it
like this now let me double-check that
yeah so we need to have these classes
and then add this as a class name so I
guess we can do it right here at the top
if we do it in the renderer yeah
crops is not defined
there we go it worked this time
see there we go 70 and then once we get
a little bit smaller see it it changes
to 90 all right wonderful - at least
everything's on a row that was rough oh
so rough okay so my time is almost up
I'm gonna go to the live chat in just a
second and check the questions and then
we'll get back to the code and I'm gonna
take a drink of G fuel try to get my
brain working so I've been having
morning meetings like really long
morning meetings for the last three days
this is my last day and it just kind of
kills you like right in the morning like
your brain is just I don't know for me
like after a long meeting my brain is
done so I try to like combat that I've
been working out every morning but like
you work out your pumps you know and
then you just sit for like an hour and a
half and anyway I'm making excuses for
my for my bad Cody
all right
not that much in the chat so I'll
probably get through this all within the
five-minute break
Rubin says hey Jesse handsome as always
is graph QL a database itself or does it
use something else I really like the way
you ask that question
started out by calling me handsome I
will just say this in general it's
normally not a great idea to you know
talk about somebody's looks when it's
off topic but in my case I'm always very
flattered by comments about my look so
I'm cool with that but I just I give the
disclaimer because I know there's
especially a lot of female coders who
constantly get comments about their
looks and it's I mean it's not they
don't want that that kind of attention
I'm not saying all people don't want
that attention but I'm saying there are
some female coders who get a lot of that
and it's it's unwanted so anyway so just
just surround it for me it's cool but
that doesn't make it cool for everybody
but anyway Rubin totally awesome I love
that that way you ask that question and
graph qo is not a database right it's
it's like an API right so like rest is
not a database but it's a way to get
data from a database does that make
sense
all right Nikki says do you need to do
that check so here's the check we were
doing here saying do we have to do that
check like graph QL will return know and
react will just ignore suffice know
you'll get empty span tags so yeah I
keep the check yeah so we potentially
would get empty span tags but also I
don't know that's kind of a good
question I don't want to take any more
time to test it out I'm gonna keep them
in there for now but what I found before
and maybe this is different because of
the way that data gets in there is what
would happen then in the data that we're
getting from let me pull this over like
we're getting this data and we would end
up having like the email field would say
email field null here and it wouldn't
have value so it wouldn't say value no
it would say email field no and that's
where we would get the error because it
would say like basically like we're
trying to look this up that doesn't
exist and I'd get an error message does
that make sense or even worse sometimes
the data comes in and like this is just
gone completely but I think this should
be good well we know this works we know
it's good we took out the data and it's
still work so but I mean at the very
least it does save us actually no we're
still getting empty span tags the way I
did it here I need to do it like this
and actually put the span tag inside of
this so we might change that I mean if I
have an empty span tag it's not the end
of the world but it's probably better
practice not to have it
I see this is already going out to lunch
with some team members we'll have to
catch the replay when I get back got to
get that ramen enjoy the ramen I wish it
was me and it says I'm fine how goes
your day Jesse yeah it not bad I got in
a good workout this morning and got to
my meeting on time I actually fit into a
pair of pants that I haven't fit into
for a long time so that was good they
were still a little like tight so I'm
not sure how tight is too tight for guys
wearing pants so I went with a different
pair but I was high excited that I can
actually get him on and button him up so
if that sounds weird to you I've been I
was on a diet been working out recently
so that's the exciting news for me so
anyway so my name's Ben I've been ok so
far thank you for asking
Oh Nicki already pointed out that I'll
still get empty span tags yeah you're
right I will still get empty span tags
so maybe we should change that up now
yeah so let's change this let's get rid
of these fantex
and let's throw in
after this end
and then here
there we go
so now what will happen is the the
entire span will be there or not
depending on whether or not this field
is there well cool you know what
honestly I'm super curious now whether
or not we even need this check so I
really want to try this so the easiest
way to do this right now it's just to
actually is to render this twice so this
one will have the check this one won't
have the check and we'll see what
happens so right now we should get it
twice which we forgot to put
there we go I needed to put brackets in
here so we were back in JavaScript land
and these would then be variables so
they're being interpreted as strings and
just add it in there we go okay so we
should have yep two email addresses and
you know what I'm I'm just gonna add
some some styles on here right now
because this is annoying me
what am I going to call this info row
and for now we'll just go display:block
so this should give us what we need
so just for now at least
okay if that look crazy I'll just
explain I use multiple cursors so I was
able to highlight multiple instances of
the same thing and then type it out at
one so all I really did was just added
class name classes info row two for span
tags and that's just as display block to
all of those come on there we go okay
now it's it's easier to read so we can
clearly see that here we have the email
address twice now onto the test let's
remove this well not phone number we're
doing email address this time let's
remove the email address update this see
what happens and we're testing to see
are basically we're testing our error
checking to see like is this even an
issue
hmm okay good to know it's not an issue
so I guess that Nikki was right let's go
to our our content here and let me grab
this data again and
no that's not how many are they'd given
me not enough let's see if I can get
faculty where the is it name
No
I can't remember the syntax for this
area name
and the scrap name here should be this
you know what let's just go with slug
because I know for sure
slug will be consistent
it's not gonna work yeah ah let's see it
works because if if the thing he tried a
span tried to access something from Nall
your console would probably throw an
error okay yeah let's just check the
console maybe I won't need to do this
you know what it still rendered these
but it's just rendering them empty so I
wonder if see that's what I want to see
what how the values coming back oh you
know what what am I thinking we already
have this here where name equals there
we go
and that's okay
and now we'll say this choice now all
right there we are so now it's the email
field value and it gives us a value
that's just it's nothing okay so because
that's the way the data comes up we
don't need to do any checks at least not
on these now the the place where we
definitely need checks is here in our
media details because you can see like
there potentially could be other sizes
here and then they would either just
exist or not exist at all so that's
where we need the checks so we could we
can either keep the checks here if we
really want to keep out empty spans we
can add to this so we could say let's go
to our ends you affect me phone field
value is not equal to like all right see
that way
there we are so now it's not rendering
empty empty spans all right wonderful so
now we're no longer rendering empties
fans and we can get to styling this
great so we started the styling process
a bit here already oops let me make sure
I put this back in this email no I
believe it was s oops it
that's pretty much how all the email
gestures go around here so I'm just
gonna go with that
so yeah so name position email phone
number CV down here great so do are we
using grid here already
we're not right disk full with your
icons
why we have this I don't know why we
have that in there let's take that out
we need we need to import grid so let's
pull it in from here now we can use grid
and now let's copy and paste some of the
stuff we did win in the sample schedule
I'll copy and paste it into here
and we're gonna put this grid around
yeah it's yeah yeah we don't want it to
be the everything in the grid container
we want to make this grid so before we
get to this content here we're gonna do
a closing tag for our our grid container
and we're also gonna add a closing well
that the first one would be for the grid
item and this one is going to be the
grid container all right so now that
works and we want to make sure after
right after the image we also close the
grid the grid item and then we open a
new grid item we'll copy this and throw
that in there and we're gonna change
these styles we're gonna change we don't
need the key so let's save it
there we are okay interesting
all right let's switch it up a bit I
want to move this outside of our grid so
what that there we are now we have the
info down a bit lower I don't know that
I really like that will mess with a
little bit more but now that I know what
I'm looking at it
I don't know Nikki says I don't need is
not equal to an empty string because an
empty string is falsie all right cool I
was wondering about that and I'm really
glad that it is did you ever go with
like you think something will work one
way but you know it will work another
way and instead of looking it up you
just go with the way you know will work
that was one of those that's one of
those times it's probably not the best
thing to do but if you're trying to get
something done fast you know you just
you do it right extra few characters in
there but really it only took a few a
second or so alright
all right so here's what I'm not sure
about so if we were to make this screen
bigger right then you would have this
stuff all the way over here I mean does
that even make sense you could flip it
around the other way maybe that would
make more sense I don't know let me know
what you think in the chat I'm I'm kind
of stuck here on on styling on what
makes more sense I mean for mobile like
this works I like this I mean I don't
think it looks that good but like it it
makes sense
it needs some styling though
but then on desktop there's just all
this space here
all right I just need to make a decision
so we need to get it done all right I'm
gonna leave it like this for now we'll
do a little bit of styling see if it
looks better once we get this cleaned up
a bit you know what we do have the class
on these rows here so let's just start
adding it right in here all right so I
definitely want font size let's go with
20 20 pixel font size and 1 i spaced a
bit so I'm gonna say margin bottom right
because I don't I don't want to have I
want it to line up with the image right
on the top so I don't want to have this
weird thing so I'm just gonna put margin
on the bottom and I'm gonna go with 8
pixels
let's see what we get all right not bad
not bad
let's see what it looks like when we go
down
actually whenever they were we'll never
really see a screen more narrow than
that and we could let's just run it like
this
all right let me know what you all think
um I'm happy with that for now
let's see Nietzsche says definitely
these kinds of things you need time if
you're not careful so I still love them
and bump the line height of the info
text next to the picture add some margin
bottom to e settle a nicer Oh perfect
this because of the delay Nicki had sent
that message before I said it but that's
awesome that we're on the same page
there okay actually I think this is fine
this is not the most beautiful thing
I've ever designed and developed here
but considering number one it looks a
heck of a lot better than what we had
and we don't have a lot of time so I
think this is fine for now so the only
other things we should do on these pages
is clean this up a bit and also increase
font size right now let's check the font
size on this right now and we're just
going to go in and change there we go
our eight-six is you know what I totally
didn't realize that I had the font size
on this stuff so small sorry for that
okay so what our eight-six let's change
our font size too
all right let's see what eighteen looks
like 18 pixels actually you know what I
really liked that I liked 18 let's go
with that so I actually have this in the
CSS because remember these are coming
from the content that we're pulling in
so we need to put it in the CSS file
it's six
oops need a separated out h6 font size
20 wait 18 18 pixels so 18 pixels I
believe is the same size as the rest of
the text on that page but because we
have that font weight there it
definitely looks like it's it's a
heading right that's what we want
and I want to check the what I have for
these h3 cuz they should be bigger than
an h6 and computed font size see it's
slightly bigger so let's let's change
those h threes
let's bump those up to 20
okay
not a huge thing but it's definitely 20
so that was a little over one pixel
difference but I definitely you know I
want that change since we we bump this
up and then clearly I believe that's an
h1 that's clearly you know bigger than
these so I think this is fine for now
okay cool that works so that's taken
care of now we just need this let's go
can we do this there's I definitely have
some some CSS in another CSS file to
handle links so in this particular
component we're pulling in just the
faculty dot CSS but I believe we had a
CSS file that included just kind of
Universal styles is anybody is anybody
listening to the throwbackthursday
playlist for today on Spotify it sounds
like it's all 90s rock music but it's
nice it's nostalgic that's what I have
on right now it's
oh here we are is it page is that the
one
yeah all right so the style sheets need
they're a bit of a mess now they
definitely need some work so for now I'm
just gonna copy and paste this over
instead of pulling all these styles in
by that I mean instead of actually
importing a separate style sheet I'd
rather not do that and I know I bet I've
been saying like we need to do this
project fast I don't have time to clean
these up you know so but that time that
needs to come before they get too too
crazy so let's see if this works you
know what it's alright it will work yeah
but realistically this is its own
component so we could probably take this
and put it in put it here but there
could be links within this content that
we're getting so we're gonna need that
anyway so I'm not at this point gonna
duplicate those Styles here so here's
the view CV you know it's at the bottom
it's kind of out of the way but I think
that's fun we had a discussion about
this yesterday I I don't think we should
be highlighting hey you know download
this PDF alright great cool and then
what I'll do after the stream is I'm
going to assign to my student workers to
look through all of the profiles all the
profiles for these professors and let me
know which ones look really weird if
there's something going on in this
content area that I don't know what kind
of markup they could have some
professors I think had like YouTube
embeds and stuff so they'll let us know
and that'll save us a lot of time in
testing but they'll let us know if we
need to account for anything else any
other type of markup
all right wonderful and my timers up so
that's perfect timing
so let's before I go back to the chat
and answer questions let's commit this
and push it up to the main repo and I'm
you know what I just now realize that I
am running angry and I could have given
you all the link but I guess I'll throw
it in there right now if you want to
just kind of see what's what's happening
very sorry about that I was right before
I started the stream I was like remember
the N growling and then I didn't
remember it all right but let's get this
committed so let's do it get status just
to double-check what we've changed so
yep we updated that quick well I updated
this query before like a few minutes
before we started we updated that
faculty j/s the CSS great so let's do a
git add atom all the yarn cm and yarn cm
you probably don't have that on your
project it's a little custom thing -
it's a little custom thing to help you
create a well formatted commit message
so otherwise you just want to type in
git commit with the little m flag so get
commit - m and then you can put your
message in in quotes let's see we really
just styled this right
yeah
and I don't think we have an issue about
this so I'm not gonna bother with that
okay so while that does its thing runs
all the tests does the auto formatting
I'm going to go to the chat please put
your questions in the chat now if you
have any questions for me to answer once
I get through everything in the chat I'm
going to end the stream all right great
now I'll push this get push awesome
now all this code is available to you on
the github repo that's linked in the
description so just check it out if you
go into that repo you can go into the
the pages folder and then go into that
faculty j/s and that's where we did most
of the work but feel free to use that
for whatever you want or add or correct
anything that I messed up all right okay
actually not that much in the live chat
so should be pretty quick free rack says
I need to learn react well yeah if
you're interested in learning reacts you
can definitely watch these streams to
check it out but there's also some
videos I think Bo Carnes did a react
intro video series sorry for the awning
and that's on our Channel right now
there's a react interest series on learn
code academies so it's will Stern's
YouTube channel and then the react
documentation is great for learning it
so that's what I would recommend free
code camp has some react stuff now in
their in their challenges as well
Elon Musk says hello hello Elon thanks
for joining
oh yeah and it looks like Ilan was also
wanting to know how to learn react stuff
so yeah so those stuff that I just said
is probably a really good place to start
I've heard that there's also like I did
the Udacity react nano degree if you're
interested in spending some money to get
more formal training check that out
I a lot of people like West bosses
courses I've never done one of his
courses but he's done react stuff react
training has has some courses so I
haven't done all these things I just
heard good things about them but yeah
there's a lot out there so but I would
say like check out some of the stuff
that I mentioned because I I know I've
either done it myself or I've heard that
they're really good alright ambition
says can you explain what WebKit and
prefixes are used for yes so when
browsers don't support something in CSS
sometimes they'll alright so this is my
I don't Lee this explanation gonna be
very official but essentially like using
those prefixes from a developer
standpoint that's a way to make things
work in browsers where things aren't
like officially supported by default
right so what is it the Moz prefix and I
don't even remember all the prefixes
usually I there's I use things that auto
prefix so I don't worry about it but if
you use those prefixes then you can get
what you're trying to do in CSS to work
so if you try to use it without the
prefix and someone's using one of those
browsers that need it then that part of
your CSS just it'll be ignored and the
reason behind it right I don't know
technically how it's all done the reason
is just that different browser support
different things in CSS officially but
they sometimes will have like
I don't like a workaround to use it
right before it becomes official and is
officially supported it's it's I guess
tested out behind this this prefix this
vendor prefix correct me if I'm wrong
about all that I just know that it works
and how to make it work I don't you know
what I'm saying like I don't know the
whole reasoning behind it but I believe
that's it but anyway a lot of times you
can find like a plugin that will work
with web pack or gulp or you know
whatever you're using that will take
your CSS and automatically add prefixes
to it so you don't even have to worry
about which prefixes to use and it keeps
your CSS nice and clean because the
stuff you actually work with doesn't
have the prefixes it gets added in later
on and you never have to see it so
that's that's really cool because the
prefix stuff can get pretty crazy if
you're using a lot of things that need a
lot of free fixes Nietzsche says
question what snack should I order to go
with my french fries I mean with like
typically like you get a hamburger right
with french fries
isn't that that's classic so I would say
that it's really hot where I'm at if
it's hot where you're right maybe get
like a milkshake or an ice cream cone
I don't know depending on where you're
at in the world but where I'm at there's
this fast food chain called Wendy's and
you keep they have these kind of like
milkshake things called Frosty's and I
know it's popular to get a chocolate
frosty and then dunk your french fries
in it and eat your french fries so I
don't mean salt and chocolate definitely
go together right so people have done
that I do it occasionally I'm not I'm
more of a fan of you know catch up with
the fries not so much to frosty with my
fries but if you don't want the
hamburger then
I recommend getting some sort of ice
cream based treat especially if it's hot
and that me that's not healthy advice
either so if you if you get if you have
health problems because of eating too
much junk food then please don't blame
me Jacob says maybe you should do a
separate design for mobile and desktop I
didn't watch at all yes so we do have
some but we have design differences
between mobile and desktop for sure so
the site but most of the site has been
designed with mobile as the primary
focus and then things just kind of scale
up for a desktop yeah but so the design
is it's there's not two completely
different designs but we just use media
queries to change things up when we need
to all right Nicky says check out the
free beginner course the beginner react
course by Kent C Dodds on egghead what'd
I say it's like egghead IO is the
address all right so I haven't done that
course but nicky recommends that also
Tyler McGinnis did a good series on
YouTube about starting with react okay
cool
so check those up Avinash this just came
what are you building
oh we were working on mainly styling a
react component using some CSS today and
it's part of a much larger project
that's been going on for I don't know
like six months going on seven months
now so yeah at this point I mean this
this strain is gonna be available to to
watch you know a few minutes after it's
over it'll be posted on the free code
camp YouTube channel so you know feel
free to go back and watch to know more
exactly about what we did
mmm Nietzsche says Vicki burger it is
very popular here in Belgium okay I've
never heard of it but I've also never
been to Belgium so that's probably what
prereq says okay
Jesse and and Brooke Brooke is Niki so I
I use it interchangeably but thanks for
thanks for recommending oh you're
welcome no problem good luck with your
with your react studies Ivan ska I'll do
that is graph QL the future kind of I
mean I would say graph QL is is the
present and the future at this point
because it's been around for a little
while and more people are using it I I
definitely see graph QL as being better
than a rest api so be it it cuts down on
the with the rest api usually you have
this problem of you make one API call
and you get a ton of data and a lot of
it you don't even need or you have split
your data out into a bunch of different
endpoints and then you have to make
multiple API calls to different
endpoints so you don't necessarily get a
bunch of extra data but you're making
all these API calls either way like
that's not ideal graph QL eliminates
that by allowing you to make one API
call get exactly the data that you want
and nothing more so just that alone is a
definite advantage because when you're
building a website you want to minimize
the amount of data and the amount of
network requests that you make all right
that's that's gonna help speed for your
site for sure it's also gonna help you
don't want to eat up people's data plans
you know on their on their phone so
anything you can do to get the overall
size you know in megabytes of your
website down is it's a good thing and
the speed also you want to get that load
time
so I think graph QL is in that category
is definitely better than a typical REST
API
Mustafa says reactor angular
well I use react I'm I haven't used
angular since angular 1 so and I've
heard that the new versions of angular
so different that I'm not even gonna
comment on really on angular because I
just don't know I I assume that angular
is good a lot of people use it but
around here
we definitely use react and I like react
so I don't really have any plans to use
anything other than react any time in
the in the near future I'd rather just
try to specialize it right now and get
get good with that a Vanessa thanks love
and support from India oh thank you
that's awesome
Ilan says how many years of experience
do you have in web development 5 6 uh I
feel like I could keep saying I've had 5
years of experience for the last like 3
years I'd have to go back for sure
you can check out my LinkedIn if you
wanna know for sure but I'm at least 5
years
Jakob says what web server is your
localhost
I'm not exactly sure what you want
transid answer that question like you
know we have webpack running handling
all the stuff of being able to run stuff
locally and that's like pre-configured
since we're using next to build it up
and I'm using n grok so that you all can
check out the site so I don't know is
any of that at all answering your
question M LV says hey can I learn react
fully for free for sure yeah there's so
many free resources out there you can
learn react and not spend anything
Jacob asks am i using visual studio
plug-in yeah I'm I have a lot of plugins
for visual studio if you're asking me
specifically to run the localhost am i
using a visual studio plug-in no it's
it's running through web pack so I think
that that makes more sense now what
you're asking
MLV says how long does it take learn
react it entirely depends on how much
time you have to dedicate to it how much
you already know about JavaScript how
how smart you are in terms of being able
to pick up new ideas so it's I mean I
say I mean it definitely took me months
before I was confident enough to like
really start using reacts on on real
projects like projects I was getting
paid for
Emily says how much of reacts what I
have to know to get into back-end
development react is front-end so if you
want to get into back-end you're gonna
have to learn either back-end like
language like PHP is widely used Ruby
you could use node if you want to stick
with JavaScript so yeah but react this
just is just front-end
I mean you can do server-side rendering
with react but you're not it's not used
for back-end programming
well why were you I think I messed this
name up before let me know how to
pronounce that well why are you says
will I get any benefits by wrapping a
REST API with graph QL or will that make
the request lower I'm not sure what it
would do on the server side in terms of
slowness of the request but I could see
client-side is that being it being
better if you did have a situation where
you would have to make lots of API calls
with the REST API and by switching to
graph QL you only cut that down to one
so I guess it would depend on your
situation if if using the REST API you
only had to make one call you aren't
getting a ton of extra data probably
okay just to stick with REST API but
otherwise it might work with the graph
kill but I you know I have no idea what
term will kind of slow down would happen
on the backend by doing that if if there
would be any significant slowdown I'm
not sure the stuff uh says thank you for
these great live streaming love and
respect for Morocco oh thank you
Andy I appreciate it MLV says fetch
versus Axios which one is better I
always use fetch I've I've heard a lot
of good things about Axios but I always
use fetch it's really simple
in terms of like if you're doing it on
the client-side and browser it's it's
supported by newer browsers natively you
don't have to import anything so I like
that so in terms of which one is better
I don't I don't know I'm sure they each
have their advantages or disadvantages
but since I haven't really used Axios
I'm not at a good position to say which
one's better alright and that's the end
of the questions and we are just in time
for the next stream to start so I
believe at 1 p.m. Eastern Time
there's going to be a live stream
continuing from earlier in the week
about creating Alexus skills which I've
created Alexis skills before and it's
really fun so if you're at all
interested in that definitely check it
out check out the the live stream and
you know make your own skill and let me
know if you do because I'll try it out
thank you all so much for joining in
thank you for all your help and for
being patient with me as I struggled
through which should have been simple
simple things too and let's see trying
to find my stop streaming button yeah so
tomorrow tomorrow's Friday I'll probably
be at home on Friday so I'm gonna try to
do a stream last time I tried to stream
from home though we had some technical
difficulties so hopefully that doesn't
happen we can work it out and get a good
stream in so hopefully see y'all
tomorrow maybe next week if I can't get
things working right
but until then have a wonderful day